this business i'm calling
only problems because forget about crime
the biggest battle is what's inside
so people in life have
basically the same five problems health
wealth relationships happiness purpose
in life
everybody's got the same five problems
right that's the dirty secret i saw tony
robbins once he goes i've helped four
million people in these seminars 22
years and guess what people have five
problems
and he goes if you think woe is me if
you think it's a big burden on you guess
what in this room right now there's
probably 500 other people who have you
know
this can have the same problem as you
whether it's with their their husband or
their kids or their parents or their
health or whatever and so a lot of
people need therapy but guess what a lot
of people aren't going to therapy it's
too taboo it's too expensive it's too
vulnerable they don't want to do it
people would rather sit on netflix and
just watch reality tv for distraction
entertainment
wait a minute
is that a great idea
is that a great idea i just heard yes it
is you turn therapy into entertainment
so it's called only problems it's only
fans for therapy
and here's how it works
you are going to
um
you pay a monthly subscription and you
get to sit in fly on the wall style to
somebody going through an actual therapy
session with the problem that you have
right with the area of your life that
you're most curious about you can go
listen to somebody vent about their
relationships about their health
problems about their career problems
whatever it is they're getting real
therapy
but they get it subsidized so they get
cheap therapy maybe free therapy
because there's 25 people anonymous
people who don't know their identity you
don't know you don't know the listeners
identity that get to listen in
and they get to back channel talk a
little [__] in the chat you don't get to
see that and um they get to sit in on a
therapy session therapists get more
clients
people get more help
and other people get kind of second hand
smoke help by being in the crowd and
getting to listen to they get the
entertainment and they get help
[Music]
all right so we're here we're gonna do
a fan favorite the drunk ideas episode
this but this episode started
when i had some business ideas that
i'll admit it i knew they were bad but
they weren't all bad they were bad good
and bad good is a separate thing
altogether bad good how do you explain
bad good you know what i mean when i say
that right
yeah it's like the lady who sells farts
in a jar like when you're telling
someone about it you're like that's
that's the stupidest [__] i've ever
heard and then she makes five hundred
thousand dollars have you seen that lady
yeah yeah this this idea is like the
beefy five burrito at at taco bell it's
bad good and so so so basically these
are ideas that i know are not great
but there's some nugget of gold in them
there's some truth to them
and so they need to be said and so you
know i think being drunk is like air
cover to saying some silly stupid things
neither of us i don't drink sam doesn't
drink when's the last time you drank
like 10 years ago ten eight years ago
when was that eight years ago
oh well i'm not like
you know i don't have like my sobriety
coin or whatever the hell like i just
like i just generally i generally don't
drink it's not like a i'm not a dork i
don't have a problem
yeah
you should lie and say you did
no no no i didn't have to overcome this
i just kind of
and the best drunk idea last time that i
still think about it all the time was
called the really long distance
girlfriend which was a service where you
just text a lady and she just becomes
your companion but you never actually
see her because she's just a really long
distance girlfriend
and she's the best kind of girlfriend
she's only supportive why because she's
paid
that's it she's paid to be great and so
you don't have to and you don't have to
be great you don't have to be a great
boyfriend she's just a great girlfriend
but at a distance and so she's a really
great girlfriend for like a lot of
people and uh
you know i should set up a call center
in the ukraine because i think that idea
still has legs uh all right so let's do
we so this time last time it was just me
this time we both were supposed to do
this
uh how was this for you i uh dude i'm
good it was
how are you all of my i've got a few but
some of them are actually like good
ideas and some of them are not even that
funny but i've got a couple i've got a
few but i want you to start
so you only have most of my ideas are
like bad bad ideas
no i've got a couple of good ones most
of mine are things that already kind of
exist and i'm um shocked that they work
and i have what those are
all right all right and so all right so
pitch
we're gonna pitch each other these i
don't know what yours are you don't know
what mine are we're gonna pitch each
other these and then ben uh producer ben
young powerful producer ben man of god
ben
ben who can still dunk and we're going
to see it this weekend ben he's going to
be the judge at the end you're going to
give us the the the
best and the worst ideas you know you
can give us the winner and the honorable
mention all right
uh
i'll go first can i go first
yeah you're gonna end up going first and
second and fourth and fifth probably
yeah
it's like a fantasy draft where i have
three of the teams yeah
okay
so all right the first idea sam it's
called hideaway
all right let me just i'm gonna ask you
a question you need to think of the
scariest things in the world maybe
you're thinking about snakes
maybe public speaking
the right that's we've heard those
studies but public speaking
is sort of silly nobody's actually
afraid of public speaking they're afraid
of public humiliation
and there's no
greater humiliation than digital
humiliation i'm talking about
you're in a work presentation and you
try to share your screen and you still
got a tab open from last night you know
that's that's public humiliation but the
worst one
is if somebody just takes your phone and
opens it up and you don't know where
they're gonna go with it
you don't know
what they're gonna open and the most i
think the most and like when they go to
your browser in the first
letter they're going to type in starts
with the p and you're like what's going
to auto bill what's going to autofill
please let me have google pbs recently
yeah
[Laughter]
so what hideaway does is it takes the
sensitive parts of and this is our first
product right we're really all about
preventing digital humiliation but our
first product our keynote product
the iphone of our mix
is a private camera roll so it's
actually going to combine two of my
favorite ideas so one we solve the pain
of somebody taking your phone or you're
trying to show them a photo but you're
scrolling through your camera roll of
all your photos which is ridiculous of
ridiculous invasion of privacy
and one of my favorite ideas or
something i've always wanted growing up
was in a movie you see those secret you
know the rich people have they have a
room in their house with a secret book
yes
so they you know they pull the fourth
book on this on the second shelf and a
secret door emerges so it's that it's a
secret bookcase it's a murphy door for
your for your uh phone
it is hideaway and so what is it it's
basically a camera and a camera roll
that is private and kept separate from
your main camera and camera roll so you
open up the app it's disguised to look
like a harmless app it looks like an
amazon kindle app it's like a book
bookshelf
but only when you tap the third seventh
and eighth books does it flip over and
it's a camera and then that that camera
roll is for your eyes only hideaway
that's the idea it could be a calculator
app it could be a book book reading app
it's got to be something that looks
harmless that even a if your parent
looked over your shoulder and saw oh
my son is just browsing the latest books
he's just doing some quick calculations
they don't know that you're actually
going to your secret camera roll all
right what do you think all right let me
let me elaborate a little bit on this um
so do me a favor and all right you're on
your computer go to search photovault
app
okay photo vault app
and you should
is the first result uh at apple
no
no the first result i see is private
photo vault pick safe and it's literally
the icon is incredible hey you youtube
guy put the icon of this on the screen
it's a manila folder
but photoshopped onto it is a giant key
lock and the key is just going directly
through the middle of the manila folder
which is incredible so this app
it's been reviewed
807 000 times
and it's 86 in the app store this app
has been around for a while and i've
looked into it a fair bit the founder
his name is william sidwell siddell um
he's based out of vegas i can't find
much information about this company but
you shouldn't yeah
he he as i shouldn't he's done a good
job but i believe he's one of the only
employees because i can't find anything
on linkedin and an app that's been
reviewed 800 000 times i mean it must
have been downloaded tens of millions of
times and they have a premium version
and the premium version they like
it does the premium version is like 50
bucks a year and it does and it stores
photos and stores documents and stores
all this [__] but what it does is like
it makes your it makes the app look like
a game and you have to do photo id and
then type in like three different
passwords in order to get to just the
photo vault password it's pretty
interesting and this app i've not seen a
lot of people online talk about it but
it's kind of a juggernaut man it's been
around forever i have to imagine that
pictures is one of the most popular
category in the app store and this has
been ranked 86 or it is 86 now and i bet
you this has been ranked like that for a
long long long time it's crazy the
amount of reviews this this is
incredible so you know so if you go to
the google play store it'll tell you the
rate download range right apple doesn't
do that but on google play this has been
downloaded at least 10 million times
says 10 million plus so that means it's
above 10 but less than 50 million that's
that range
and um and that's just on google play
let alone and we i mean
you know how i feel about android
so yeah so we know you know i'm already
i'm already thinking if google play
if google plays at 10 million you just
you know what my boys on apple are doing
and
by the way i don't know why i said that
there's a guy in the youtube comments
it's always like dude sean's always
sean's always got a comment about
android he just does a laughing emoji so
i decided to make that my thing um but i
don't really have anything against it uh
but for the record i do all right the
the key feature of this that i didn't
have in my pitch
decoy password
so uh sometimes a nosey person wants
into your private photo yes if you have
a dummy password that will show you just
a random set of safe images and they
think they got in this guy thought of
everything bro this is amazing dude it's
fascinating so let's just if we assume
that google has 10 million which would
mean that um
apple probably has five times that right
so 50 million so he's probably has 50 to
60 million downloads ever
if you assume okay yeah
well if you well if google is 10 million
right you said it's at least why would
apple be 10 why would i have to be five
times more there's more google users
some more android users well then maybe
my math is [__] up so let's just say
it's equal
let's just say let's just say that it's
uh 20 million you don't have to believe
that he did that with two g's fugged up
yeah two g's
in fact if your kids are in the car turn
the volume up that was fine what he just
did so that was good like [__] this shiv
um
[Laughter]
it's good uh so like
if he has 20 or 30 million downloads do
you think it's i don't really remember
uh like app conversion rates is it crazy
to think that he would have
a three percent conversion is it crazy
to think that you'd have one million
paying uh premium users
not crazy not crazy
so it's 40 which means this guy has
probably
gross
in the lifetime 40 million bucks from
his premium version let's just put it
this way
at the bottom of the page the copyright
2011-2020
says it's from
legendary software labs llc
and i just got a call from the state of
delaware
and they said there's never been a
better better named company that company
name was perfectly appropriate we've
reviewed it
we triple stamped the double stamp and
that was correct this is a legendary
software and uh my drunk idea is
validated all right you're up
[Laughter]
all right um
i found something that it seems like it
came out of a a drunken like bar hangout
one night so do me a favor go to
santasclub.com
santa's club oh god is this
are we going nf nsfw here
uh no it's safe it it that it could go
either way but no that otherwise
actually everything's safe for work now
we're working it from home bro like that
that thing needs to be gone
all right all right that's a good point
have you seen not not safe for life
[Laughter]
on reddit i go to these uh forums and
some of the stuff are tagged uh not safe
for life and it's hilarious it's it's a
pretty like it'll be like someone
popping a zit and it says not not safe
for life okay so i'm on santa's club
there we go thank you
so santa's club it was started in 2020
this guy named will uh evelsizer started
it and each year about 15 000 people
come to his site and they spent around
and it only up this business only
operates two months out of the year and
basically if you go to the yes if you go
to the website what you're going to see
is like your typical look at santa claus
in a studio
and he
you get to spend 15 minutes and you do a
virtual
santa sit on their lap ask what you want
for christmas type of thing for only 10
or 15 minutes and he's got like a studio
probably in nevada where instead of cam
girls it's
just fat santas and he makes
according to i read some articles about
it in the first year he had 15 000
visits and prices range from 35 to 75
dollars per visit which means he's doing
around 500 000 to a million dollars in
only two months and if you go to the
website now he's got like a pre-sale
it's 100 sold out you can't buy anymore
the guy's got to go get more santas
dude this is
hell this is genius this is hilarious
this is not even a good bad idea this is
simply a good good idea so
i like this i think i kind of like a
little bit better cameo for for santa's
so i'm gonna i'm gonna give you i'm
gonna give you a little side dish there
which is santa for cameos for santa's or
sam jeff campbell in fact steven he came
on the pod i think did he come on the
punt former duke guy built cameo he
needs to just implement this in the
cameo this holiday season well this is
it's very clear santa santa's club they
just got to get the easter bunny the
tooth fairy what are the other like uh
characters
yeah that's great
that's what you gotta do
uh ben do you guys got some holidays
where you need a little uh character of
some kind yeah like a joseph smith like
a guy in a beard with like eight wives
we got pioneer day yeah maybe you know a
pioneer type dude
that could work
no we're just gonna
we got the christian holidays we got we
got easter and christmas sorry i can't
do more for you we're going to call it
fairy inc and the employees are going to
be the fairies
and
um we're going to have easter bunny
santa
tooth fairy what else is there
i i forget what i don't know what else
there is
there's are we gonna have any copyright
issues because that's also what we call
morning brew on the download oh
[Laughter]
this is a good business it's pretty cool
so it started off as a drunken idea but
it's actually cool i have this lady who
i have no i think she listens to the
podcast and she fretted me on facebook
and she dresses like elsa like from
frozen and people pay her money to do a
call like she like has you know she's
like a disney uh like
this is great it's cosplay
but like you know a paid little cameo
call or recorded video that makes a lot
of sense to me like i know that's like
you know obviously copyright but like if
it wasn't right santa that's that that's
that makes sense easter bunny tooth
fairy those all make sense
that you should be able to do this uh
you know and especially if you did it on
demand somebody could just rip out like
hundreds of these in a studio every
single day
just being like oh amanda
you know ho ho merry christmas your mom
wanted me to tell you you've been doing
great job with blah blah blah
see you later
next video and like each one of those is
forty dollars a pop
you know how like on webinars i think
you'll see
you'll see like business webinars and
it'll be like neil patel who's on the
pod and i'll be like hey everyone this
is neil are we live is this thing
working is this on and it's like fake
like it's a recording but he but he acts
like it's real and you see people in the
comments like hey neil what's up and
he'll say like hey derek from chicago
how are you and like you know it's just
it's just a recording it's all fake
you know you could do this you could
obviously you could do the same thing i
hate when what webinars like that
well i don't know if neil does he
probably does i think i have seen him do
it but there's a lot of webinars that
are like that and it's like a recording
but what they do is they like put uh uh
like replies in there and they just it's
you know what i mean it's all artificial
it's all fake
but it they make it look real and it's
pretty good wow phoning it in okay uh
amazing okay so i give this a good good
idea i think that's that's solid
uh anything else on this or can i hit
you with my next one
hit me
all right
what's the name of a fast-growing
company that does billions of dollars
and serves
creators all around the world
it's bigger than twitch
they provide private photos and videos
to their fans
if you subscribe you might be considered
only their fan that's right only fans
now only fans is a great business model
the owner of only fans listen to this
podcast and they crush it they are
absolutely phenomenal business but
i got to thinking what other space could
you do this in
and so i was sitting there and i was
thinking and i and you told me about a
app that somebody had built called
police scanner police scanner plus or
something like that this app that does
millions of dollars a year
and i just i couldn't get that out of my
head i thought who would do this why
would anybody want to listen to like a
dude i listen to it all the time if i
hear a gunshot or like a loud
backfire of a car i immediately open it
up and i'm like all right let's see what
what what what's going on here was it
real or was it not
and so there's a curiosity component
people i think just like listening to a
train wreck in a way they like to
observe from a safe distance
do you have the app called citizen
citizen is just like this yeah where
it's like you know dude i had to quit
using that because when i'm in brooklyn
like i'll pull it up it looks like my
phone screen has chickenpox like there's
red dots all over the place and i'm like
there's crime everywhere you know what
i'm saying like i can't be doing that
anymore
so okay
this business i'm calling
only problems because forget about crime
the biggest battle is what's inside
so people in life have
basically the same five problems health
wealth relationships happiness purpose
in life
everybody's got the same five problems
right that's the dirty secret i saw tony
robbins once he goes i've helped four
million people in these seminars 22
years and guess what people have five
problems
and he goes if you think woe is me if
you think it's a big burden on you guess
what in this room right now there's
probably 500 other people who have you
know
this can have the same problem as you
whether it's with their their husband or
their kids or their parents or their
health or whatever
and so a lot of people need therapy but
guess what a lot of people aren't going
to therapy it's too taboo it's too
expensive it's too vulnerable they don't
want to do it people would rather sit on
netflix and just watch reality tv for
distraction and entertainment
wait a minute
is that a great idea
is that a great idea i just heard yes it
is you turn therapy into entertainment
so it's called only problems it's only
fans for therapy
and here's how it works
you are going to
um
you pay a monthly subscription and you
get to sit in fly on the wall style to
somebody going through an actual therapy
session with the problem that you have
right with the area of your life that
you're most curious about you can go
listen to somebody event about their
relationships about their health
problems about their career problems
whatever it is they're getting real
therapy
but they get it subsidized so they get
cheap therapy maybe free therapy
because there's 25 people anonymous
people who don't know their identity you
don't know you don't know the listeners
identity that get to listen in
and they get to back channel talk a
little [__] in the chat you don't get to
see that and um they get to sit in on a
therapy session therapists get more
clients
people get more help
and other people get kind of second-hand
smoke help by being in the crowd and
getting to listen to they get the
entertainment and they get help have you
ever seen this movie honestly honestly
i'm gonna just say it right now
i
wrote this idea down and i got
i got goosebumps under this hairy arm
yeah you got a little little arm
mountains dude have you uh have you seen
the movie fight club
of course
so it there's like one of the premises
of the movie is that this guy
ed norton i guess he's tyler i don't
know i forget his name tyler jordan and
then he meets that woman that's like the
love interest and what they do is
they go to terminal cancer anonymous
meetings
and i don't know why i forget why but
they like it makes them feel alive and
it like makes them feel happy because
they think that they're all screwed up
and they're like i want to go meet with
people who are actually dying and it's
like oddly therapeutic for them
what you're describing is kind of like
that where you sit and you're like
oh wow this guy really is [__] up i'm
straight i'm good you know what i mean
yeah gratitude as a service right
it ain't so bad after all we say
so bad yeah
it could be worse
[Music]
yeah and and that's the thing the
crazier your problems are the more
vulnerable and open you get the more
people tip your little hearts in the app
the bigger rev share you get as part of
doing that therapy so
you're incentivized to be screwed up
you can just make stuff up to be honest
with you but like you're definitely a
jury springer right why do we like jerry
springer
why do you still watch your springer
reruns every morning before work because
we like to watch other people have f'd
up problems and then see them deal with
it and we like fights also but that's
the that's what i'm tapping into here
i'm but i'm doing it through an app
i'm doing it
it's called only problems
and
honestly if you're going to run with
this you better hit sean at seanpuri.com
that's all i got i need i need to see an
email from somebody trying this idea i
feel i genuinely feel like this is one
of those ideas that's like no way and
then it gets huge
it reminds me of uh like the people who
want to go watch someone do surgery have
you ever seen like those like setups
where you were first no so for um
for like if you're a student like
there's these medical rooms that have uh
it's like it's like a two-way mirror
almost yeah and you have like it's like
watching an execution almost like you
just like sit there and you just like
watch what they're doing that's what
this reminds me of have you ever been to
this subreddit called uh popping
no but i i was gonna bring up
the addictive way that people watch you
like pop a blackhead or a pimple or
whatever dude there's a subreddit
there's a subreddit called popping i've
been on the front of it yeah you see
i've been on the front page you see this
scar right here
uh yes yeah so i have a i have a big
scar on my because i had like a
ping-pong ball-sized thing like growing
like on my brain and i had to get
surgery like in 2014 to get it taken out
and right before i go under i go to the
surgeon and i go hey man do you have
your iphone on you he goes yeah i go
can you save my number and take some
pictures uh when i'm under so you can
like get some like before after and
during pics of uh a surgery so i could
post it on our slash popping
and he did it he he texted me and i got
these like beautiful photos of like this
this growth like being popped and
scraped off my brain and i posted it on
that subreddit and i got uh like 80 000
views on my photo album and so uh i'm a
member of our slash popping i love it
and so you may not have a blue check
mark on twitter but you always have this
put this in your bio put this on your
linkedin front folder front page yeah
former front page major serial front
pager of our slash popping
dude i have it i i i have to find it and
said it to you but you see like you know
like and then he also like cut some fat
from my stomach and then he like puttied
it into the hole
and like you so you like see this whole
process of like there being a girl out
of an apartment and you can hung up
something so you got to fill a hole yeah
he took a little fat off me and he just
like putted that bad boy in and i woke
up and like my stomach was hurting i was
like dude i thought you're going to take
it from my leg he's like no your leg was
pretty muscular so we just took some off
your stomach you had a lot there
so it just kind of like tickles flex but
okay yeah well
i have muscular legs not always a
muscular stomach and anything one of our
creeds kudos is we don't mess with
perfection so i couldn't touch the legs
so anyway uh on board with only problems
good idea
thank you thank you all right uh you got
one or you want me to go third also let
me let me i'll this is the last one i
probably have well i got one more but uh
all right
the biggest this is this is a little bit
of a stretch but i actually don't think
it is that much of a stretch
the most popular business publication in
the world
by digital audience what do you think it
is most populous what most popular but
the most popular digital business
publication in the world by traffic
um
so there's wall street journal there's
uh
marketcap.com coin market cap that's a
good guess that probably does uh how
much probably 50 million a month in
yeah
so
there's wall street journal there's
financialtimes.com there's coin market
cap there's business insider business
insider probably gets a lot i'd hypo i
would say and i'd hypothesize the
largest business publication in the
world is run by basically two people
and it is called
slideshare you ever been to slideshare
i love slideshare wow that's so i
thought you were going to bring up
drudge report again by the way no
slideshare so slideshare is this site
that was started by i forget her name uh
but she's an interesting founder she's
like pretty outspoken on twitter and i
like her a lot anyway she's right indian
woman yeah she started it and she sold
it to linkedin for like a hundred and
fifty million dollars and slideshare was
most indian social network of all time
just powerpoints
that's what slideshare is like way to
slack up but make your parents proud at
the same time yeah
did you see uh our our buddy sheila he
just got engaged and he goes i have an
aunt who doesn't speak english she only
knows a few words but the only words
that she knows she texts me all the time
and it says are you married yet
andy like posted screenshots of uh of
the of her asking that in perfect
english are you married yet please be
married please be married um
so slideshare it's just like a it's just
a website where you upload [__] right
you upload decks um well linkedin bought
it in 2012 and it just sat there and
then scribe do you know scribed or is it
scribd script scribd they bought it and
i'm almost certain looking at linkedin
and looking at the website that like one
and a half engineers are the only
employees working on this
um and they were for sale for a little
while so i so like i don't think this is
entirely guessing but basically they get
between 100 to 150 million visits a
month and most of the content or about
half but it could be at this point most
is like marketing decks pitch to pitch
decks conference decks on a business
strategy and it makes virtually no
revenue if you go there you won't see
any ads and it's just this website that
does 100 to 150 maybe 200 million
monthly visits
it's this juggernaut of a website with
if you look at the website it hasn't
been updated in years and years and
years and years here's my idea
if i were a b2b company if i were
salesforce or a hubspot or if i were um
i don't know anyone selling like
software or anything that sells people
to
[__] for people who goes to like you
know these like business conference
i would buy it and turn it into a b2b
legion website and i think that you can
make a ton of money off this website
because here's why any website that gets
a ton of traffic from user generated
content once it hits a critical mass
which slideshare does it's like
impossible to stop you know what i'm
saying it just keeps going and it's
almost impossible to catch up with that
it's really really really hard so i
think that this website is just sitting
there floating along not doing anything
and it could actually be a business that
makes nine figures a year through ads
which is like the best revenue of all
time when you don't actually have to
like make anything yeah you have super
high value customers because it's only
business people that are gonna be doing
this uh so and who bought them didn't
linkedin buy them at some point or no
linkedin bought them in 2012 and it just
sat there and they did nothing with it
and then they sold it easy to me yeah
and they i think they paid 150 they paid
nine figures for it and then they uh
sold it to scribd and if i had a bet
scribd like linkedin was like just get
this off our hands just don't fire
anyone who works on it and like assume
all the liability and like just it's
yours just go just go away so um check
out this tweet i just put in the chat
okay
it says uh it's from you and it says
free 500 million dollar idea
reinvent and relaunch slideshare all
right great great mindset like if
if there's a talented engineer designer
who wants to do this i'll give you money
and share my one page plan on how to
attack this
all right dude we're on the same page
here i think
do you want to see my one page plan yeah
you can't it doesn't exist i just wrote
that out and i was like if somebody
actually reaches out that's interesting
for this i will come up with a one-page
plan of how i would do this because
to me slideshare is so ripe for the
picking
it is completely neglected it is
extremely valuable as a like a potential
tool it never really got replaced
properly by something else and it didn't
become obsolete
and uh
and it's just one of those like big
opportunities hiding in plain sight and
i would love to basically brainstorm how
to how i would attack this kind of
slideshare problem but the opportunity
was missed linkedin if you know one of
us or someone listening had a little bit
of like charm and suave and was able to
get connected with the linkedin people
they would have given it to you it would
have been like
it would have been free i don't know
about because scribd isn't a big enough
company where they're like oh yeah here
we don't give a [__] just take it but
when you're owned by microsoft they're
just like i imagine they're just like
we can't focus on this right now yeah an
undisclosed price this would have been
uh
i mean i can't imagine this was that
much i i could be wrong but like it
didn't make any revenue i feel like they
probably got like 10 million or
something or less
yeah
wow or less missed opportunity that is a
serious missed opportunity that's not
that drunk of an idea but anyway it's an
idea
um all right i got another one let me
let me let me make it i'm all out by the
way
i
you don't wanna know how long this list
is um
and it all came to me in one giant flood
uh
i just dumped them all out what do you
what do you do do you just like come up
with like names are you like michael
scott where he just like has a name for
something and he builds a business
around it
no joke that's part of it um
my thing was sort of like
you have to find something relatable
either something that really sucks or
that's really awesome and then just use
it in an unexpected way
right so like
um
you're just smashing two things together
exactly so i saw this like the hidden
bookcase thing and i was like oh my god
i freaking always wanted one of these
where i hit the three piano keys and a
door opens or i pull the bookshelf book
i tilt the book out and it like opens a
secret door
so how do i take that awesome thing and
just use it in an unexpected way and
that's where that idea came from have
you ever seen have you ever seen those
for guns so uh you well i've thought
about buying one of these where you can
put like a shelf like you know how you
have a shelf next to your front door
that you put your keys on
yeah
you can buy some of these and you click
a button and it opens a little bit on
the bottom and you just grab your pistol
and they're pretty sick
that's pretty cool okay i like that
put like my fanny pack in there maybe
for when i leave the house like some
cheez-its
but would it fit a regulation-sized bag
of corn nuts
[Music]
all right so speaking of work backers
from a great idea here's the here's the
name of this one
i mean
ben you might want to get your pencil
out for the top winner of the episode
instagram ahanas
that sounds a little weird
like benihanas
it's benihanas
for
photo opportunities okay so here's how
it works
it's a restaurant that's not about the
food it's a restaurant about the content
like the museum of ice cream baby people
roll in their eye it's like the museum
ice cream but it's seated
and it is uh like basically people go to
restaurants they order food and they'll
order like oh we got a fishbowl drink or
we're drinking beer out of a shoe and
like oh we got the huge like donuts at
the end and they take pictures and it
becomes content or like they use
sparklers instead of birthday candles
now i started a restaurant i know all
the problems about restaurants you got
all this food waste you got high labor
costs
you don't actually you're not running
this like a restaurant so here's how it
works it's like benihanas you go there's
like i don't know 30 tables you sit down
every table seats like eight people and
you go as a group and you're going for
an experience you're not going for the
food and um two things happen so
basically food is gonna come out
that and each one is photo worthy food
either because it's gross it's funny
looking it's huge it's so indulgent it's
right it's like you know a giant pile of
sour gummy worms it's oh it's a it's the
the mega green doughnut how are we ever
gonna eat this oh look it's so funny to
watch me try
that sort of thing oh the
this guy's gonna come out and you know
we have to drink this giant beer can
that's like you know 36 ounces or
whatever i don't know but a big beer can
360 ounces let's say um and so that's
the that's the idea it's all
photo worthy food it's brought out like
omakase and a studio we're gonna call it
the uh
the food porn cafe
instagram mahanas is the name but um if
you'd like to launch a competitor bring
it on
there's a drone camera that just flies
right above the table and it's just
recording the whole thing and it's just
gonna
it just dumps it in a google drive
folder and there's a guy in india one
guy who's editing everybody's photos all
night everybody's content all night and
at the end you're gonna get the three or
four best reaction shots because the
food gets revealed you know like
no it's like it's like when you get a
picture on a roller coaster exactly it's
exactly but we're using outsourced labor
the drone is capturing everything and um
and and the food and it feels like a
party there's a dj you know like those
new york brunches for cool people
this is that for fat people so instead
of being cool and having to like know
how to dance and stand up on the table
and drink champagne at nine in the
morning you sit
and food comes out that's crazy and you
get to eat it and you get to make a big
mess and it's gonna your reactions on
your and your attempts are all all photo
and video recorded hundred dollars a
person plus tips eight people per table
i'm thinking you know 20 maybe 30 tables
uh you know two or three turns per night
and uh we're talking a million dollar a
month easy on this food cost is way down
because it's not even real food you're
just doing like giant popcorn and silly
stuff you know no proteins you don't
have to worry about that there's no food
waste because it's
you're just bringing out one thing for
the table to react to yeah yeah yeah
lighting each person your f your five
pound burger doesn't need to taste good
exactly it's like benihana there's like
a harvard business school case study on
how amazing benihanas is and one of the
reasons is like
because they put there's no kitchen
space they use the whole restaurant for
like uh
for dining because the the chef is at
the table the stove is the table
basically
and um they have like higher labor costs
because they have skilled chefs but they
have way lower like you know uh they use
a real estate better and like their food
waste is way down because they have a
limited menu so it's you kind of do all
that smart stuff
um how do you instagram honestly what do
you think i'm in i'm into it have you
ever heard the background of benihana
the guy
rocky i think is his name yeah so he's
basically we wrote about it it was one
of our most trafficked trafficked
articles for a long time he's basically
you know he's an immigrant came here
with nothing and then you know who his
son is is steve aoki the the dj oh no
way i did not know that yeah and this
guy rocky i think he i forget the
article but it was like one of those
like most interesting man alive stories
where like he had been involved in like
porn and then benihana's like got big
and then went bankrupt then he bought it
back and it went big again and then he
was like this international man of
mystery like uh it's a really
interesting story and people love that
company and it's still crushing i went i
we used to go to team dinners there i
[__] love benny honda's but dude i'm
into this bring it up dude when we're in
like a car and it's like oh we're gonna
be i'm like i think there's a benihanas
around here
but i'm just like i'm just waiting for
that to latch somebody to be like that'd
be fun never i never get any support on
it i'm always tossing the little
benihana you know test flare out there
like uh you know i guess we could do big
group stuff
they got good tables
no one ever bites i don't know why i'm
like i've been i'm over 12 on this thing
how is that remember that guy you
brought up on instagram during the
pandemic who started that cookie
business that just made the most
ridiculous cookies you remember like
what's like a dealer i think is it
how's he doing
great i checked in with nominee i don't
know i think they're doing fine i'm not
sure i ordered cookies honestly they
were not great something i'm sort of
like uh what's the fuss but that's kind
of how a lot of these food crazes are
like the expectations get way out of
whack and what about me's a museum of
ice cream so the museum of ice cream
they started a little bit before the
pandemic and you and i like or a bunch
of a lot of people made fun of them
because they raised like 50 million
dollars at a 250 million evaluation and
basically i don't even think they serve
ice cream there right it's just like a
ball pit and like funny ice cream stuff
and you pay like 20 bucks and you go to
take pictures right
yeah you've never been to it
no
it's like a haunted house you walk from
room to room each room has its own like
kind of crazy thing and sometimes you
get to eat a little bit but most of the
time it's just photos with like cool in
a cool room it's instagram content
in manhattan i walked by one recently
and the line was around the block and
i've gone by it a few times and there's
always a long line to go in i think they
they have to be killing it right
uh i thought so but then the sf1 closed
so i don't know what happened but uh
well sf closed
right
so
uh but the manhattan one
the manhattan one is just i mean that's
really when it's like sf just like shut
down for maintenance so they just spit
down for like four years
um museum livestream said the same thing
that every like tech person in san
francisco said just ah [__] it i'm out
of here
yeah it was like an audible sigh
of just like ah fine i'm out
yeah
uh i think um yeah i'm on board with
this i think it's good we did a
breakdown where we talked about like the
companies like crona and like fondue
only stores and like all these companies
it was like what do you have to do you
have to take like you got to take a food
and put it in a weird shape or a weird
size or a weird color
yeah or you match a weird container
a weird container yeah or you mash two
things that are kind of related but not
entirely related like a burger in the
shape of a hot dog or a cronut or
something like this loco taco whatever
the big taco bell thing
exactly or you take something that's
typically a side or a topping and you
make that the only thing like a cookie
dough only place that serves it in an
ice cream tin or an ice cream thing what
else were they i forget what they were
you're like the the rain man of figuring
out this food trick like everybody else
just saw each one of these it's like oh
that's weird that's weird and you're
like i see the pattern yeah
we're like i mean what what's wrong
what's wrong with the left side of your
face right now i need to go to you're
downloading it i figured i'm figuring it
out no it's it's all rooted in like an
eating disorder like i go to i go to
food therapy and uh uh like you know i
need to go to your therapy and talk
about i use i pay a lady seven hundred
dollars a month just to talk about food
every single morning clearly there's
issues there yeah so i just used
anything for the time
yeah the amount of times that i've eaten
a jar of jif peanut butter in one
sitting is god damn just way too high
it's way too high we need a gif of you
just eating a jar of jiff in one sitting
that's have you ever done an nft
dude i've eaten a full jar with just a
spoon multiple times it's just too
addicting
habitual line stepper all right i have
more let me give you i got maybe one
maybe two more let's see how it goes um
you probably don't watch this show
but there's a show that's hot on netflix
called indian matchmaker have you seen
it of course i watch that show you watch
it okay i thought this might be only
entertaining to indeed people because
it's like no
dude are you kidding me i watch it all
the time and in my head i'm just
thinking
y'all are screwed up
you guys are so weird
like what are you kidding me
like
how is the suicide rate not higher
amongst you people
you're like yeah don't make me send the
british back in there all right you guys
got to get your [__] together
what the hell man like there'll be this
like beautiful doctor
in her 30s making money she's pretty
she's nice and her mom's like yelling at
her like criticizing her for not being
married it's crazy
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
[Music]
so
my sister called me last night after
she's like i finished season two
and she just goes i need to ask you
something it's not too personal i was
like oh what's it gonna be
she goes
when you first met
uh when you first met sonya did you
did you have a game because on the show
the indian guys have zero game and i was
like
like what do you mean like i guess so
and then she's like no think about like
she was like and she's like these guys
they're nice guys they're smart guys
they're like you know they're they're
good job they're normal people they have
no crazy drug habits the reason they're
still single is because they don't know
how to look at
talk to or touch a girl
and i was like oh yeah i had that
problem
yeah
that's me too actually you're right dude
i saw uh i saw someone post a picture of
a painting of a naked woman from like
the 1700s
and it was all indian guys commenting
saying like hey baby i love you i love
you for a long time text me call me
yeah that's like if if you're ever a
girl who does like live streaming on
like whatever twitch or like whatever
periscope whatever app uh
they're all like what is
why are there so many men in like turkey
the middle east and india who will just
they just flood their chat and they just
keep saying show bobs show bob show
bombs
and then they say he'd say show bob's
so you didn't have game
you were you were you were uh
so so i asked then i asked my wife i was
like i was like yeah my sister asked me
this i was like i don't think i did did
i she's like no you didn't and i was
like uh i was like she's like you know
you had a different type you had like
intellectual game like she's like you
were good at like telling stories or you
would say interesting things and that
counts like that's like the basic like
man [__] she's like you didn't know how
to like kind of like
you know
there was no smoothness to like the oh
we're walking down the street like let's
just i just hold my hand without like us
having like the first time like how do
you do that smooth the first time or you
know like in san francisco the streets
are a little dangerous she's like you
know you would always like walk on the
inside of the street i'd be on the edge
like right by the cars and the bums and
like you know you didn't know to just
like stand on that side just like the
little kind of male protective instincts
a little bit like you know pull my chair
out you know let me sit down first
that's like you know
don't say like see ya when we leave like
you know say something else like you
know like
and it's like i was like i opened the
door for you she's like yeah you would
like open the door and be like scoot in
like screw all the way across and then
i'll sit on this i'll get in after you
it's like you know you're supposed to go
to the other side and like open the
doors for me and then you go to the
other side i was like oh yeah like
that's so much effort like you know it's
fine um
and so there was a whole bunch of things
like that and i remember i dated a girl
once
in australia and i'll always give her
credit she was she kind of was like an
amazing girl and she taught me one thing
which was she was like you know whenever
you're i actually didn't even really
dave was kind of in the flirting phase
but she was like
um she was teaching me how to she was
like a dancer she was teaching me how to
do like she was like [__] like champion
or some [__] like that uh and or
something i think [__] is fighting
[Laughter]
and she was like okay so just like put
your hand here and whatever and then she
like looked at my hand i was like i put
it right what you said
and she's like yeah but look at it and i
looked at him my hand's like you know
like limp basically it's like my hair
was there but like there was a firmness
to it it was like you know it was
nothing and she goes if you're gonna
touch a girl touch with intent
and i was like
oh and i literally have never forgot
that that was like 15 years ago and in
my head i'm always like i got taught a
real like lesson in like man stuff uh
that day of like how to do like do
things with girls like touch with intent
and i was like i didn't even really
understand what the hell she meant but
like that was the first time i got
taught so here's the idea
basically it's swag school and it just
teaches indian guys how to have a little
more game so you go to a seminar it's
like toastmasters or alcoholics
anonymous and you go and you sit in a
circle and first you just say
uh you know my name is sean and i am
awkward and then everyone says welcome
sean and then the next guy says hey my
name is pradeep uh dr bay area um and i
am awkward ever since
it just goes around the circle
and it's going to teach you how to how
to look at a girl how to touch a girl
how to have some presents how to sit
straight stand up straight how to dress
how to go in for a kiss and there's just
a girl there to teach you how to do it
because guess what
you can't learn it in a textbook so
that's it swag is cool what do you think
love it um have you heard do you
remember art of charm our friend jordan
he's got a new thing jordan harbiture
but now it used to be called art of
charm do you remember that it's like a
um
was it like a five day boot camp for men
is that what was it five days
i don't really know i know he has the
podcast and i used to read the blog
so listen to this he spoke at one of my
events and he talked about it and so it
was him and two other guys they had like
a falling out so this is like before
they had the falling out and the
business was called art of charm and it
was teaching men how to be more charming
and he would also teach like he would go
and talk to like navy seals and talk
about like how to use charm to like you
know like blend in and [__] like that
and so
they were making if i remember correctly
10 million dollars a year hosting these
what did you just say they used to go
teach navy seals how to use charm to
blend in with what like the water
water
like he was like you know what all this
espionage training you're doing
no no
that's what he did
you need to learn from me
no that's what he did it was like uh
like i don't [__] know like uh that's
just what he told me he was like he they
called it uh operators or something like
special op special ops
dude i want to start a company that's
called fortune 500 and so people can be
like oh yeah i work with fortune 500
companies
like you know hey you're not lying
it sounds cool when you're pitching your
services
it's like
dmv.org or whatever that works i'm gonna
make this navy seals s-e-e-l-s and you
could just say yeah i train navy seals
well dude so he was making like 10
million dollars a year hosting these
like four-day boot camps and i knew a
guy who went to one and he said it
changed my life and this guy ended up he
was this dorky guy who i'm friends with
and he married this beautiful awesome
woman and i was like making a joke to
him like how'd you pull that off and
he's like man i went to this art of
charm boot camp and he just taught me
how to like be more confident and like
talk to women and it totally worked so
long story short swag school
down
on dtf with swag school all right well
you validated me there okay great so i
think we i have more i have so many more
um but i think we save it if people like
this we can make this a recurring thing
this is the second edition of drunk
ideas let us know what you think in the
youtube pretty good right
at least pretty good
all feedback now in the youtube comments
i'm replying i'm reading every single
one i don't want emails i don't want
twitter i only want youtube comments now
are you all you're you're on board this
youtube train it's going to my head is
it going to your hands it's so much fun
yeah like hey the videos get more views
now we're out of the pathetic range
where it's like 3.3 000 views
i'm just like oh man like you know
it's like i kind of want to
it's like i need to like make a
disclaimer it's like but the podcast is
bigger like you know like yeah i used to
say that all the time i'll be like well
the podcast it's like
yeah yeah it's mostly podcasts we just
started youtube but now you don't have
to print out your podcast stats it's
okay
no now i think a lot of episodes will
get 20 30 40 000 views on youtube so
yeah and i'm about it and the comment
section it is interesting also some of
these people are just
really stupid there's so many stupid
commenters like you see some of the
stuff they post it's like what do you
what's this have to do with anything
uh so there's a lot of stupid stuff oh
and there's so many scammers the typical
scam is the scammer is so annoying so
there's one scammer that acts like he's
us and then there's another scammer
where it's like
um i totally agree with you and that's
why he starts
the first guy this guy he's pretending
to be us he replies to every comment and
his thing is my first million but he's
using like emoji for the letters it's
like and the m is like a yellow yeah
yeah that's something he's like come
join my whatsapp group yeah come in my
whatsapp group he's trying to scam you
on whatsapp
and then the other one is so annoying
it's always the top comment on every
video and i'm like my mission in life is
to like eviscerate this person i hate it
and it says i totally agree with what
you just said in fact that's why i
started following aunt linda she's
taught me all i need to know about forex
trading and crypto trading if you're
interested here's her information and
then somehow they get like 80 people
yeah to comment and so it like goes up
number one and it looks legit
and it's like
the best i was skeptical at first but
she really turned it around for me
oh i turned 2000 into 18 000. thank you
so much linda linda if you're reading
this blah blah blah and it just goes on
and that's all the comments and it's the
top comment on every youtube video
for any finance related channel it's so
annoying it's like you know with the
economy the way i totally agree but with
the economy the way it is nowadays
investing is harder than ever i'm so
thankful for for you know dr baldwin's
investing um uh whatsapp group i you
know it's really been a life changer for
me and then everybody's like dr baldwin
is amazing and it's like the same thing
every single day it's such a good idea
it's such a slick scam it's a really
well done scam and i can't but i can't
stand it um so anyway yeah i'm on board
youtube that's our place now which means
you're gonna have to start like where
this is my jacket so you gotta like
start you gotta get like a jacket or
something you gotta get like a look
well i just have this so
yes i gotta have a look you're
absolutely right
in fact i tweeted that out i said i need
a look
and uh people gave me a bunch of bad
ideas so i'm still looking for a good
idea um all right well who won uh okay
am i giving grades or am i not giving
grades pick a pick a best idea honorable
mention and a worst idea
i think
uh only fans for therapy is the best
idea it is like both funny
and is actually a good idea and um
i just like i would watch i know i could
pass like four and a half hours on one
afternoon like the first half hour i'm
like this is so stupid but i don't quit
the app and then like four hours later
i'm like this is so stupid and i'm still
honey come listen to this guy he's so
stupid hey everybody on social media
come listen to this it's so bad
yeah
it's like me and johnny k plus 8.
um
uh
for worst idea i got a since i just
pumped up shawn i gotta take him down a
notch and say instagram ohana's worst
idea uh because i feel like you need one
food if your whole
shtick is like all these different foods
that are instagramable uh
also just like a lot of people are doing
this in different ways
instagram mohanas zero out of ten one
food would be enough but i just like to
over deliver so yeah you know one of my
greatest weaknesses
and what was the pepperoni you asked for
uh what is oh i was gonna say you can
honorable mention one of sam's ideas
perhaps because you know otherwise
i you know my honorable mention is i
wish that sam had done swag school i
wish sam had come on here and been like
so you know how indian guys have no game
[Laughter]
actually missed opportunity
that was
hilarious all right
[Music]
you